[Music]
alright guys I have a question from an
advice column and I will read it to you
that we can't give advice because it's
legally wrong but we'll give certain
your opinion opinions yeah okay here we
go it says I've been dating a guy for
nine months and totally fell for him
through a conversation I found out his
ideal life is to have a main and two
side women what he previously forgot to
mention is that he's already doing this
and has been having sex with others but
I'm the main and he just wants variety
in his sex life what do I do
should I be proud that I'm the main or
hurt that he isn't happy with just me I
don't want a poly relationship but I
don't want to lose him either can have
balls girl what the [ __ ] first of all he
forgot to tell you deep in some [ __ ] he
forgot oh I forgot and she's the main
what more does she want she wants him to
quit the other ones she wants him to be
something that she can't have him be
like he doesn't want that because his
ideal life is to have more than one
woman and yeah it kind of sucks for her
though that he didn't open up with this
yeah because that's kind of trickery I
think it sucked that she's not
supporting his dreams you don't think
it's wrong that you kept this from her
and then now with nine months in now it
just services she's trying to control
him and I mean she she's very rigid and
conservative now yeah that she's getting
all of her needs met so why does she
want him she's not gonna your needs met
what would her needs the word means that
she would like to have her man to
herself I mean but don't you think you
should always support your partner no
matter what yes especially if you want
them to live their passions exactly or
if they do it okay I think what they
need to do to solve this is to have an
experiment right so you write down what
do you want from your man and then so
she's like okay cool monogamous period
and then so he's the monogamous man as
she always dreamed of right and then
she's like okay cool this is
Awesome's what I've always loved now you
introduced the variable so she could he
brings in one side chick right did this
main relationship change she's like nope
you're just as good as before then you
could have one now you introduced the
second one and then finally you can eat
transition your way back well what about
that black and white where it's not
about just the relationship between the
two of them but then for her it also
feels like well whether or not we're
good one on one the fact that you are
still being with other people and might
possibly bring something into this
relationship
[Laughter]
because the only thing that changed is
her knowledge she was totally fine and
happy up until the point that she found
out there were two other women her sauce
she found out so it's her fault that
she's upset that she was being deceived
you got me there that's your one
argument I mean what are we gonna do we
can just sit here and say wow this guy
sucks well I mean in her okay in her
first like she still wants a man that
wants to [ __ ] around so that that's what
I don't get
because if I was at her shoes and I
heard that immediately I'd be like well
I I love the dude but that's not the
life that I want yeah and if he still
wants to [ __ ] around he's not ready for
a steady relationship well straight up
and cheating on her 100% wholesale
multiple chicks and then he's all you
don't know what he told her baby at the
polyamorous stuff that sounds like it's
an excuse to be cheating yeah I don't
know if that's run less it's agreed-upon
ahead of time cuz that's not cheating if
it's Jack it walked into it knowing yeah
he must have told her or basically she's
under the impression that they're in a
relationship monogamous like loving
relationship right but that means the
way he framed it the way that he dated
her the way he approached her wasn't
like hey I want to love you and [ __ ] you
but [ __ ] other girls it was more like I
want I'm I'm looking at you as dating
you dating with you marrying you maybe
you know it's not it's like
the the frame was all [ __ ] up this cat
was like sitting at dinners with her and
[ __ ] anyway so what's your favorite
movie what's your favorite like TV show
what salsa and then she's like oh do you
have any other questions for me he's
like no when his ideal lifestyle was I'm
sure he talked to my parents all kinds
of stupid [ __ ] that had nothing to do
with anything
oh by the way I [ __ ] a lot of other
girls what have you he's fried you know
he's like like you see a dog walker you
see that dog were like eight dogs that
looks like a very happy life I tried so
many times to apply it it's fine I was
just so blind that she can't see all the
cool islands like that he's straight up
hey baby I've had Donuts and he's like
oh you don't want just one and one of
the donuts is a big one right and a
little smaller that's the main donut
[Laughter]
they're just fillers she's just not
getting it I think no yes she's a little
dense the funny thing is she's asking
for advice as if like that breaks my
heart
people are gonna know you know what
she's really asking for is do you think
I can change him in heels you see that
all the time right that's like the idea
of somebody more than the actual person
because she's essentially like yeah I
love him but I just don't like who he is
doesn't have the courage to just end it
yeah that's why she's on this advice
column I think she's asking for a little
bit of strength from other people or
some confidence to kind of carry on or
to end it so what if all of the women
here on the forum or side pieces and
they're like girl you don't know how
good you got it
you're the main one
and they're all dating that same gun
what if they all were like you are so
ungrateful you [ __ ] you're the main one
they like you know he spends all this
time with you he gives you his emotions
we're out here [ __ ] it oh they're
like what's-his-name
oh my god he says I'm the main he says
oh my god I'm sure that happens - sure
hey you're the side okay alright let me
by yes okay to zero in on what he
previously forgot to mention no just no
move along find someone who not only
wants what you want but who can
communicate transparently about what
he's up to
the slightly longer answer should and
feelings together in the same sentence
make me nervous use you should feel how
you feel your emotion emotional response
is legitimate and valuable no matter
what that that response is you might be
feeling a little bit all of the above
actions are where we get into should
territory sometimes we meet wonderful
people who aren't a match for us and due
to one fundamental opposition or another
you don't want to pull your relationship
that's okay it's not for you don't force
yourself you aren't gonna be happy in a
relationship structure that isn't within
the bounds of what you want this is a
really long reply to say [ __ ] this guy
Wow like they don't know how to
summarize they're just pointing out the
obvious this reminds me of a situation
that happened to one of my close friends
she um I didn't know during this but she
told me after the relationship but I
didn't know that she was in a
relationship where she was being
completely lied to by the guy but all
the evidence points to she was the side
piece right so the guy is with a woman
having a kid with this woman oh right
but he swears this isn't serious yeah
he's with my friend right and then he
claims that he's gonna leave this lady
that has his kid but you know he's kind
of fine
the right time because there's a kid
there also timing is really important
right and the subtle evidence that he
was a sidepiece was that she had he had
a whole other family Wow well she bought
him a car right she helped him with his
business right on top of that she moved
in a block away from him and got an
apartment there because she's kind of
scary right well he probably is like yo
those apartments right been right next
to me right where she just stayed there
on her own [ __ ] dime right right and
I'm all like damn dude you [ __ ] post
mated your [ __ ] to him and you paid for
it yeah and you have no idea she goes no
no but you don't understand like when we
go out in public like he gave me he and
Judy peaceful Magnum McDonald's as his
girlfriend to his friends and I'm all
like guys will [ __ ] do that though
and then say hey guess what this is my
girlfriend
don't tell my way don't tell ya what the
[ __ ] like I'm like man I was like
honestly you you're that's it's good you
got away from that [ __ ] cuz you were
just you were just a side piece like you
don't get it she goes that was the main
one and I'm like damn why it wasn't she
living with him then you know because
there was a kid and she had a [ __ ]
car seat in her car because for the kid
for some other girl's kid Wow how was
this gone on Maury to me what blows my
mind is she's highly [ __ ] successful
yourself she's like licensed for that I
bet your eyes were like it's difficult
for me to say she's banging and smoking
because she's like a sister to me you
don't know if her sister's bankers well
unless they're Carmen Electra are like
someone like for sure I've said it
before my sister's hot spot yeah as a
brother with a sister you can register
that your sister because I don't have a
sister's I wouldn't know if my sister
was average
I think she's ugly as [ __ ] unless she's
like smoking and undeniable I think
that's different and my sister I had a
kid had two kids filled out her ass
looks better than ever
[Laughter]
and you can call me on that and no one
the poor today is made for Steve
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]